normalerweise prüft der bundespräsident
gesetze er vertritt deutschland im
ausland und ab und zu hält er auch mal
eine große rede aber was ist in zeiten
wie diesen mit krieg inflation
klimakrise und deutschland im dauer
krisen modus wie schaut der erste mann
im staat auf den zustand unseres landes
und muss er sich vielleicht mehr
einmischen das frage ich heute hier in
hamburg frank walter steinmeier herzlich
willkommen zum zdf sommerinterview
[Musik]
ich würde sie hallo herzlich willkommen
zdf philharmonie in hamburg ganz
spektakuläre ort und eigentlich auch
sehr passend zu den themen die wir heute
zu besprechen haben angst vor der welt
in deutschland sie werden auch heute
hier noch eine rede halten in hamburg zu
einem festakt sicherlich auch noch mal
über den zustand der welt reden deshalb
treffen wir sie heute hier wenn wir von
hier aus auf die welt schauen da draußen
die verändert sich ja gerade ganz massiv
und wir bekommen das hier auch kräftig
zu spüren in deutschland
machen sie sich gedanken darüber ob wir
gerade dabei sind dabei zuzuschauen wie
das die art und weise wie wir hier leben
in der freiheitlichen westlichen welt
gerade vielleicht zu ende geht es sind
glaube ich zwei dinge wenn wir hier
stehen ist das erstmal etwas was mich
begeistert begeistert weil der hafen die
schiffe die betriebsamkeit alles das
steht sozusagen für eine einbindung
deutschlands in die weltwirtschaft steht
für weltoffenheit für vernetzung in der
weltwirtschaft und das ist ja keine
selbstverständlichkeit dass ein kleines
land wie deutschland exportweltmeister
ist 82 menschen 82 millionen menschen
sorgen täglich dafür dass wir vierter
welte viert größte weltwirtschaftsmacht
sind trotzdem wir dürfen nicht
ignorieren es gibt gefährdungen und es
gibt risiken und darüber wird zu
sprechen sein das scheint gerade massiv
bedroht zu sein durch die pandemie durch
den krieg durch inflation die menschen
machen sich große sorgen viele menschen
haben existenzängste was ist denn jetzt
die richtige strategie den menschen zu
sagen das wird schon alles wieder gut
oder muss man sie darauf einstimmen das
alles schlechter wird ja ich glaube die
menschen denken mit und sie verstehen
die signale aus der politik viele
verstehen dass das ein einbruch in eine
normalität ist die wir jetzt zum
gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt erleben wir
haben 16 jahre hinter uns sind der dänen
in denen wir stabiles
wirtschaftswachstum hatten jährlich
sinken der arbeitslosigkeit und jetzt
müssen wir mit risiken umgehen die sich
aus dem verminderten energiebezug aus
russland ergeben und mit steigenden
preisen ich glaube die menschen haben
vertrauen in die politik dass sie
möglich ketten und wege finden dass wir
unsere stabilität politische stabilität
und wirtschaftliche stabilität behalten
über die risiken und die rezepte der
politik reden wir jetzt gleich noch
drüben bei unseren tisch
[Musik]
der bundespräsident wir befinden uns
jetzt momentan in einer zeit der
multiplen krisen wir hatten eine
pandemie jetzt kommt der krieg noch dazu
die menschen haben sorgen wegen
steigender preise vor allem
energiepreise und nahrungsmittel wohnen
ist seit langem für viele menschen schon
kaum noch bezahlbar der paritätische
wohlfahrtsverband er hat in dieser woche
neue und zwar erschreckende zahlen
bekannt gegeben man hat gesagt allein in
den zwei pandemie jahren sind noch nie
so viele menschen so schnell in armut
abgerutscht wie jetzt und das trotz
zahlreicher
hilfsmaßnahmen der bundesregierung jetzt
kommt noch mal die inflation dazu da
stellt sich doch die frage reichen zwei
entlastungspaket um den menschen zu
helfen ich denke die bundesregierung
wird das so im auge haben wie wir beide
hier in diesem gespräch es ist völlig
klar dass das was wir im augenblick
erleben an energiepreissteigerungen
solitär ist das haben wir noch nicht
erlebt vierfach höhere preise nicht nur
an den tankstellen sondern auch vor
allen dingen für das gas was gebraucht
wird und die heizungen zu hause zu
betreiben dasselbe gilt für die
industrie ich glaube es ist ein sommer
wenn ich das so sagen darf der
zwiespältigkeit will sagen auf der einen
seite herrscht natürlich freude darüber
dass ich will nicht sagen nach dem ende
der pandemie hre nachdem es jetzt
möglich ist nach zwei jahren wieder in
urlaub zu fahren freuen sich die
menschen zunächst mal auf einen sommer
mit ferien dafür sprechen die
buchungszahlen aber das ist natürlich
ein zwiespältiger sommer weil die
solidarität die die deutschen gezeigt
haben eine belastungsprobe ausgesetzt
wird und zu dieser belastungsprobe
gehören ohne zweifel auch die steigenden
preise wichtig ist dass die politik im
auge hat dass es eine gerechte
lastenverteilung gibt und da haben sie
völlig recht die pakete die es bisher
gegeben hat waren gut und war notwendig
haben sogar dazu beigetragen dass die
inflation wenigstens etwas gebrochen
wurde aber man wird die situation weiter
im auge haben und instrumente überlegen
müssen wie man insbesondere den
geringverdienern wie man denen das leben
erleichtert
und rentner auch kinder und nicht
erwerbstätige sind diejenigen die ganz
besonders betroffen sind insgesamt 13,8
millionen menschen die laut bericht des
paritätischen wohlfahrtsverbandes jetzt
unter die armutsgrenze gerutscht sind
sie haben gerade schon gesagt
gerechtigkeit ist das thema momentan
sieht es fast so aus als wäre
deutschland zu arm um die schwächsten zu
schützen was muss dann wenn er konkret
passieren entlassungs pakete sind
geschnürt worden das haben sie in ihrer
frage eben selbst gesagt zweitens
natürlich wird nicht jeder in gleicher
weise von den entlastungs paketen
betroffenen insofern wir sind im
augenblick bei einem zwischenstand die
bundesregierung macht hier nicht den
eindruck dass ihr die entwicklung
gleichgültig ist sondern hat ja
eigentlich jenseits der objektiven
möglichkeiten
gesetzespakete beschlossen die zu einer
wiederaufnahme von schulden führen und
insofern bin ich ganz zuversichtlich
dass die bundesregierung sich auch
weiter kümmern wird dafür sorgen wird
dass diejenigen die bisher jedenfalls
nicht betroffen waren von entlastungen
und die am untersten an der untersten
ecke der sozialen skala stehen dringend
auf hilfe angewiesen sind dass die nicht
aus den augen verloren werden sondern
dass denen geholfen wird ihre wohnung zu
bezahlen die heizung zu bezahlen die
frage ist wie schnell muss das passieren
ich frage das deshalb weil christian
lindner der bundesfinanzminister schon
gesagt hat ein weiteres entlastungspaket
auch für die besonders betroffenen in
diesem jahr kann es nicht geben dafür
reicht das geld nicht aus ist das aus
sicht des staatsoberhaupt das die
richtige prioritätensetzung das ist doch
keine frage dass die finanzminister
darauf achten muss und sagen muss dass
der staat in einer solchen situation in
der wir solidarität zeigen mit einem
land in unserer nachbarschaft des brutal
und völkerrechtswidrig überfallen worden
ist kann doch der finanzminister gar
nicht versprechen dass jeder nachteil
ausgeglichen wird aus dem staatshaushalt
das gibt auch ein großer staatshaushalt
die der der bundesrepublik schlicht
nicht her weil ich bin ganz sicher dass
die bundesregierung die weitere
entwicklung im auge behalten wird und
sorgfältig darauf achten wird das
die belastungsprobe von der ich eben
gesprochen habe unsere solidarität nicht
am ende so ausfällt dass uns die
menschen von der fahne gehen man könnte
vielleicht noch mehr menschen entlasten
wenn man die schuldenbremse noch einmal
aussetzen würde das möchte die
bundesregierung aber nicht tun ist es
tatsächlich jetzt die situation zu sagen
in einer solchen ausnahmesituation hält
man an einer roten linie fest die
eigentlich mal für normale zeiten
formuliert wurde
dazu sind jetzt gerade entscheidungen
getroffen werden in dieser woche hat das
bundeskabinett über den haushalt beraten
und entschieden das ist jetzt der stand
mit dem wir uns im augenblick befassen
müssen ansonsten habe ich dem
bundesfinanzminister in dieser sache von
diesem tisch aus keine weiteren
ratschläge zu geben sie drücken oder
großes vertrauen in die bundesregierung
aus die zahlen verunsichern aber dennoch
die bevölkerung wir haben jetzt gerade
gehört dass gaspreise zum beispiel bis
zu 400 prozent teurer werden könnten
insgesamt die menschen ringen mit den
globalen veränderungen auch mit der
angst vor dem krieg mit mit
existenzsorgen sie fragen sich was kommt
da noch auf uns zu wann wenn ich jetzt
müssten sie als bundespräsident da eine
große rede an die nation halten um eine
orientierung zu geben das ist das was
ich tue in allen meinen öffentlichen
auftritten weise ich darauf hin dass wir
die normalität nicht in alle zukunft
fortschreiben können das ist ein
epochenbruch in dem wir uns befinden
keiner hat damit gerechnet dass putin
den totalen wirtschaftlichen politischen
moralischen ruinen seines landes in kauf
nehmen und wird für die erfüllung seiner
imperialen träume das ist aber passiert
und deshalb ist das ja keine situation
in der wir uns hier in der in der
bundesdeutschen nabelschau finden können
sondern wir müssen sagen das ist jetzt
ein bruch mit der normalität es kann
auch sein dass wir mehrere harte jahre
vor uns haben aber wir sind mit unseren
möglichkeiten mit einer starken
wirtschaft mit einer vernetzung in der
welt sind wir besser aufgestellt als
viele andere aber niemand kann im
augenblick versprechen dass die
belastungen uns nicht erreichen das
spüren die menschen sie sagen sie machen
das in den termin die sie haben bei den
öffentlichen auftritten ich habe extra
noch mal nachgeschaut in der liste ihrer
auftritte ist keine große regel krisen
rede an die nation enthalten seit
ausbruch dieser krise was hält sie denn
zurück zunächst einmal sind wir in einer
zeit in der die bundes bundesregierung
sich mit allen möglichkeiten bemüht die
energieversorgung so gut wie möglich
sicherzustellen
die tatsache dass wir uns aus der
abhängigkeit von russischem öl und
russischem gas befreien wollen ist ja
nichts was der bundesregierung so
eingefallen ist sondern ist eine folge
dieses krieges und der reaktion mit
sanktionen darauf das ist jetzt eine
debatte über die richtigen instrumente
und der bundespräsident sollte sie sich
nicht elitär instrumenten debatte
einmischen aber er sollte sehr wohl
sagen dass satte jahre sind die auch von
zu kommen und das habe ich gerade heute
nachmittag beim übersee club in hamburg
getan
wir haben mal geschaut die meisten ihrer
vorgänger hatten keine zweite amtszeit
sie selber sind aus freien stücken noch
einmal angetreten zur wahl haben dass
ich ja auch große aufgaben vor auf sich
zukommen sehen das war aber bevor
russland die ukraine angegriffen hat und
was danach passierte das fast mal unsere
kollegin hat geht es ja wieder mal in 60
sekunden zusammen es waren ungewohnt
deutliche worte mit denen frank walter
steinmeier nach seiner wiederwahl putin
kritisierte deutlicher als alle wegen
des kanzlers bis dahin ich habe lehrern
präsident putin lösen sie die schlinge
um den hals der ukraine ein neuer ton ja
aber die vergangenheit holt ihn ein vor
allem der ukrainische botschafter
kritisiert heftig die nähe steinmeiers
putin und zulauf als kanzleramtschef als
außenminister nach massiver kritik räumt
er ein da habe ich mich wie andere auch
gehört doch alle fehler eingeständnisse
helfen nicht in kiew steinmeier
unerwünscht seine geplante reise mit dem
präsidenten von polen und den baltischen
staaten
sie findet ohne ihn statt ein
beispielloser affront offenbar war das
in kiew nicht gewünscht von angela
merkel die gemeinsam mit steinmeier in
ihrer russlandpolitik auf dialog und auf
handel setzte keine selbstkritik ich
werde mich nicht entschuldigen so die
ehemalige kanzlerin herr steinmeier in
sie haben über ihre eigenen fehler schon
gesprochen die kanzlerin entschuldigte
sich nicht enttäuscht sie das
nein ich habe gesagt aus der sicht von
heute mit dem wissen von heute war die
unterstützung von 19 2 2014 nach der
annexion der krim ein fehler oder eine
fehleinschätzung das problem des wissens
von heute ist dass man es damals nicht
hatte insofern sage ich das was wir
damals im jahre 2014 versucht haben und
da kann ich mich ja gar nicht
distanzieren von von der bundeskanzlerin
war der versuch einen krieg der im gange
war einzuhegen dafür zu sorgen dass es
nicht ein flächen krieg in der ganzen
ukraine wird der unterschied zur
situation heute ist er dass es damals
der ukrainische präsident poroschenko
selbst war der deutschland und
frankreich um hilfe gebeten hatte bei
verhandlungen die mit russland um einen
waffenstillstand aufgenommen werden
sollten dazu haben wir beigetragen das
mag man aus heutiger sicht als nicht
ausreichend empfinden aus der damaligen
sicht war es der versuch die ukraine zu
unterstützen und zu schützen vor
weiteren angriffen dass da am ende die
umsetzung des minsker abkommens nicht
funktioniert hat über viele jahre hinweg
ist zuzugeben trotzdem weil der versuch
richtig die frage ist ja welche lehren
kann man ziehen wenn man sich nicht ganz
ehrlich macht ich habe in einer ihrer
reden einen schönen satz gefunden der
lautet sinngemäß wer an einem besseren
morgen arbeiten will muss der
vergangenheit ins auge sehen das haben
sie gesagt haben sie denn das gefühl
dass diejenigen die in den letzten
jahren die verantwortung getragen und
ist ja teilweise jetzt auch noch tun
dass ausreichend tun der vergangenheit
ins auge zu sehen das will ich jetzt für
andere gar nicht sagen aber wissen sie
wer in der politik verantwortung
übernimmt der geht das risiko ein dass
er sich irrt das wird immer so sein für
meine generation auch für die nächste
generation die frage nach der schuld der
immer so gerne gestellt wird nach der
bei der energieabhängigkeit wo beginnt
man wo endet man
sollen wir der regierung brandt
vorwerfen dass sie das röhrengeschäft
zugelassen hat sagen wir die regierung
schmidt vorwerfen dass sie die röhren
gefiltert sollen wir der regierung kohl
vorwerfen dass die abhängigkeit von mose
vom sowjetischen gas damals schon einmal
bei 50 prozent lag also ging es zurück
man könnte ja schauen was hat man in den
letzten schritten gemacht und was kann
man daraus lernen weil eben einige der
beteiligten auch noch er wird die
schritte in die abhängigkeit dieser
zurecht thematisieren die hat eben eine
lange geschichte und wir haben eigene
beiträge dazu geleistet indem wir gesagt
haben wir verabschieden uns von der
kernenergie wir steigen aus der
steinkohleförderung aus wir beenden die
die braunkohleverstromung das alles hat
dafür gesorgt dass im energiemix in
deutschland das gas eine dominante rolle
bekommen hat und deshalb natürlich auch
die die die steigerungen der der
liefermengen aus russland zugenommen
denn lassen sie uns nicht nach hinten
schauen sondern nach vorne und auf die
frage wie ist dann ein besseres morgen
für die ukraine
möglich die frage ist ja führt der weg
dahin über diplomatie oder über einen
militärischen sieg der ukraine
also meiner sicht ist völlig klar
die ukraine muss ihre souveränität muss
ihre territoriale integrität muss ihre
unabhängigkeit wieder gewinnen die frage
ist ob mit diesem bekenntnis und alle
fragen gelöst und es gibt die offene
frage nämlich wie wir dieser krieg
beendet wie wird das blutvergießen
beendet und das können wir sozusagen
nicht mit bekenntnissen lösen im
augenblick ist es so und das können wir
in diesem gespräch nicht
nicht verändern dass die entscheidung
auf dem wenn sie so wollen schlachtfeld
gesucht wird aber die erfahrung sagt
auch sagt mir auch dass jeder kriege am
ende am verhandlungstisch beendet wird
das ist der schluss daraus wir müssen
die ukraine in eine lage versetzen in
der sie etwas zu verhandeln hat nehmen
wir sie stark machen bevor verhandlungen
beginnen aber sagen wir den einsatz noch
sagen der einsatz ist ganz wichtig wir
werden die ukraine nicht drängend
sondern es bleibt und ist eine
entscheidung der ukraine
wann sie diesen weg geht und die nato
hat jetzt auch noch einmal gesagt wir
werden die ukraine so lange unterstützen
wie es nötig ist können sie uns sagen
auf welchem zeitraum sich deutschland
einstellen kann ich nicht sagen aber das
ergibt sich aus dem satz den ich eben
gesagt habe wir werden die ukraine nicht
drängen an den verhandlungstisch
anzutreten das muss eine ukrainische
entscheidung bleiben und da bin ich der
meinung wie die nato solange werden wir
die ukraine unterstützen die sie haben
einmal gesagt putin ist heute ein
brutaler eingebunkert kriegstreiber mit
dem muss man sich jetzt
auseinandersetzen wenn wir mal schauen
wie die einladung zur g-20 gelaufen sind
zum gipfel in indonesien dann sieht man
so eingebunkert scheint er nicht zu sein
putin wird dort sehr wahrscheinlich
neben olaf scholz am tisch sitzen oder
mit olaf scholz am tisch sitzen zeigt
das nicht dass wir da auch ein bisschen
einem selbstbetrug aufsitzen wenn wir
glauben dass russland völlig isoliert
ist ich weiß nicht wer de einem
selbstbetrug auf sitzt da war ich sage
seit geraumer zeit wir dürfen nicht
davon ausgehen dass die konfliktlage
noch die alte ist und dass die welt sich
fein sortiert nach einem definierten
westen und auf einem definierten osten
ich würde sogar heute im gegenteil sagen
gerade wenn wir uns aus alten
abhängigkeiten befreien wenn wir unsere
lektion lernen aus dem was im deutsch
russischen verhältnis schief gegangen
ist wenn wir lieferketten
diversifizieren gerade auch in bezug auf
china dann müssen wir uns neue partner
suchen dazu gehören länder die die ich
gerade besucht habe seine mannschaft
weil sich von china zu trennen
die abhängigkeiten in einzelnen
rohstoffen und vorprodukten von china
ist größer als 50 prozent größer als
beim erdgas von russland insofern wird
das ein langer prozess sein aber die
unternehmen haben schon gelernt die
lieferketten ketten verändern sich schon
die
produktionsorte werden diskutiert das
heißt wir werden mehr produktionsorte
weltweit haben aber wir brauchen eben
auch partner und das sind länder die
werden sich nicht ohne weiteres als
länder des westens zugehörig fühlen
sondern wir müssen die länder suchen die
vielleicht nicht zu 100 prozent alle
unsere werte teilen aber die dasselbe
interesse haben wie wir dass wir
miteinander agieren miteinander
verhandeln auf einer regelbasierten
ordnung dass wir das völkerrecht
beachten und vertragstreu sind es sind
epochale veränderungen die da auf uns zu
kommen egal was die politik jetzt
entscheidet sie stellt weichen deren
folgen dann von künftigen generationen
geschultert werden müssen wie gerecht
ist das für die jüngeren
mit verlaub das war immer so dass die
jüngeren auf den schultern der älteren
stehen bei den entscheidungen die in den
generationen vor mir getroffen sind war
das auch so und wir haben mit
entscheidungen umzugehen gehabt die
unsere vorgänger generation getroffen
haben das wird für die zukünftige
generation eben auch so sein aber wir
haben in deutschland jedenfalls keine
verantwortungslose politiker elite die
nicht rücksicht darauf nehmen was wir
der zukünftigen generationen aufladen
will sagen an der dringlichkeit des
kampfes gegen den klimawandel besteht ja
kein zweifel und wir dürfen da
geschwindigkeit nicht verlieren selbst
wenn wir uns im augenblick andere
probleme belasten große
herausforderungen der bundespräsident
ich danke ihnen sehr für dieses gespräch
ich danke ihnen das war der auftakt zu
unserer sommerinterview reihe in der
nächsten woche geht es weiter mit dem
vorsitzenden der linken martin
schirdewahn und mit der existenzkrise in
der sich die linken befindet ihnen
herzlichen dank fürs zuschauen und einen
schönen abend
[Musik]